I Marty ramamurti I am now the founder
and CEO of lamoid will i'll tell you
what Lou Moyes I am an engineer by
education I'm masters uncle in software
engineering so I build products at
Microsoft before this I worked on Xbox
Live visual studio and the CLR the
common language runtime building a bunch
of products there and then joined the
netflix movie streaming team which built
the software which lets here watch
Netflix shows and movies and stuff and
then I started Co founded this company
called true and go which is actually an
intimate apparel startup where we apply
a machine learning algorithm to go with
fit women online and from there it
applied to Y Combinator got through the
program launched lamoid we launched late
last year and since then just been
building and scaling the business so
what is lamoid lamoid is a try before
you buy service for gadgets so we
started in photo video gear entirely
focused on consumers who want to try and
buy really high-end gadgets medium to
high end gadgets but didn't wanna
splurge right away so we provided a
rental model and then if you are
interested you could buy but there's no
commitment to buy and we worked with
secondhand stores used electronic stores
to get inventory from them in a more
ties the whole thing so that's kind of
how we started the business and like
most other startups we had no money to
start with we basically said okay we
have to go figure this out in scale out
the business and I have no background in
sales or marketing and so we just had to
go figure this out so these are five
lessons that have been relevant what
I've learned building lamoid most of
these might not be applicable to you if
they are great if they are not and if
there's anything else that I can help
with let me know offline and we can chat
what are the five things if you're going
to talk about building things things
that do things that don't scale you've
heard this before everyone talks about
this what are the things that didn't
scale that we tried in the beginning
what worked what didn't we made a ton of
mistake
and that's the only way we could learn
some of them worked and we applied more
resources towards it some of them didn't
work spectacular failures and we learn
from that and moved on getting the
basics right what are the basics in our
business what worked for us and what did
we apply what our happy customers how do
they help you with marketing standing on
shoulders of giants for us what what
does that even mean and finally Ohio
will come to that so doing things that
don't scale when we started out we were
renting and selling cameras lenses
things like that I used to be a
photographer I had expertise starting
out the business so how did we go reach
out we would do the absolute craziest
things I am a runner I would run and
right then about last year they started
building the Bay Bridge lights and lots
of photographers used to show up and we
would go when I was running around
embarcadero I would hand out cards to
all of these guys and I would say you
should come check out lamoid and try
this out his service and for the first
month I think people were just like I
would see them just toss out the cards
and just keep moving and then they would
come in they would actually try out the
server say like oh yeah I heard about
you guys and they were just like pay
attention to us and that kind of worked
out in the beginning we would go talk to
community colleges and we found out that
most community colleges had issue rooms
where students can get gear for free but
these issue rooms had incredibly dated
equipment so we were able to get these
students to go talk to their teachers
and convince them to talk about us and
work with their issue rooms to provide
gear to them so that worked out really
well for us this is something that I
would pick up the phone and just start
calling and get people to come on board
we would when we send out cameras we
would send out lamoid straps along with
the cameras when customers saw their
other customers they crying out gear
they would say what is lamoid and they
would come check out the service we've
had a number of customers just come in
because if I saw somebody where a loom
wide strap I mean these are like very
simple things but it just ended up
working out pretty well for us and just
scaling out the whole side of things
every time we sent out a box we made
sure we had a really good
Packaging experienced people love
opening the box it's really pretty and
we put in a card there this is send this
card to somebody else you really like
and they'll get a discount they can all
fly in referral program kind of thing
and that worked out really well because
the card was beautiful and they wanted
to share it with everyone else and we
got traffic through that just figuring
out ways in which you can get the
initial set of customers without having
to spend too much on marketing or spend
anything at all meetups calm stuff like
that those were the ones that really
work for us to start building a
foundation for the business and of
course once you get enough traction or
you get a little bit of PR you can kind
of scale build and keep building on it
but these were the initial things have
worked for us getting the basics right
everyone talks about like hacking your
way into getting million users for us
one of the things was just focusing on
the fundamentals we are an e-commerce
company so we want to go measure the
absolute important metrics measure
everything and you will not believe the
number of startups who I talked to would
be like yeah we yes we have customer
acquisition numbers LCV aov but our
startup is a little bit different
everybody comes and tells me that their
startup is a little different and they
can't measure the number is exactly like
how they're supposed to yes you might
have exceptions but more often than not
you're probably the norm somebody else
is doing something similar to you are so
go and measure every aspect of your
business I mean it's not impossible yes
it takes a little bit of work but put in
the effort to the point where if you are
non technical or if you have employees
are the people in your company who are
non-technical you want to be able for
them to just be able to look at the
numbers it doesn't have to be pretty but
generate a few scripts and you know push
them into some UI something that they
can all look up so build measure
everything that you can in my case we
look at how much are they spending where
are they coming from how much does it
take to acquire the customer how long
are they retaining what does the churn
like basics of the business get those
right first and then you can figure out
other growth tactics and hacks in there
the basics have always worked out pretty
well for us and just optimizing that
our referral programs print money for us
it's worked out really really well we
only started this a month ago and we
were kind of everybody told us yeah
referals everyone's doing referrals it's
not a big deal its kind of saturated
turns out it's not I mean this is still
one of the good ways to go acquire
customers just the fundamentals and
focusing on that worked out really well
for us customers when I purchase from
amazon or when i get a box shipped to me
i would never ever send them a thank you
note but it turns out that a lot of our
customers actually write handwritten
notes like this whenever they're
traveling travel is a big segment for
Lou muy where we ship gear to their
hotel destinations if you are say
vacationing in Hawaii we ship a box to
you and once you're done you can ship it
back to us right from there without
having to carry gear with you and so
people when they travel they get a
postcard the right stuff and they put it
back in the box it's just amazing to see
why customers would do this we use we
collected a lot of these cards and
handwritten notes they get their kids to
go right in the boxes and stuff like
that so at one point we just had a white
board full of just these cards and then
we said okay we're going to just create
a tumblr that just puts up all of these
and customers now love contributing to
that tumblr they would send us a card
and then they'd be like can you put it
up on that blog you have a blog for it
and that kind of became this competition
where people who just want to like write
thank-you notes and write stuff or they
would talk about us on Instagram and
then we would put it up on tumblr and
they'd be incredibly excited about it it
was just one of these like really easy
channels for us to pay back to the
customer without having to really do
much about it so in general for us if
you have happy customers they are
basically free marketing for you they
would talk about you I remember I think
our fourth ever paying customer they
came on board and that guy
single-handedly referred 11 other paying
customer stood it and pretty high ovies
for each of these guys and we didn't do
anything we just had like really good
service and he would just come back and
tell his friends he posted on facebook
and people just came through because of
that so if you have one is do you need
to have happy because
basics of any business but when you do
have them make use of them they'll be
happy to spread the word because they
have friends who might be similar and
they want to tell them about you Yelp
it's again something that we started
looking at about two months ago same
thing everyone said okay it's really
saturated everyone's on Yelp what's the
big deal we put it up on yelp now we had
at five stars really good service there
people write about us they are the you
know every time they have a good
experience they go talk about it a lot
of customers find us on yelp it's it's
amazing the number of people locally
find us from there they would call us
and Yelp has a great metric system they
tell you how many people have looked for
directions how many people called from
the page itself and stuff like that yelp
who's worked out really well for us and
it does really well when you search and
when you find a service like ours same
for facebook customers tell their
friends through no Facebook itself we
boost we promote those posts those work
really well for us reviews food
photographers mom photographers mom
bloggers we basically work with these
guys either as an affiliate basis or we
work with them as an influencer give
them free gear rentals for a weekend and
they would just do a review for us it's
the ages works out and instead of us
having to build platforms build long
form content build all of this we
basically working with these guys to
just make it happen and that just works
out really well and finally Ohio what
happened was when we first started out
the business law and for investors came
in and said I know who your target
audiences it's all gadget geeks these
are people maybe San Francisco may be in
New York who are really interested in
high-end gadgets and they have
disposable income they want to try stuff
you're basically looking at our tech
folks in the coastal areas but it turns
out that a predominant number of
customers are bang the middle of the
country Ohio's one of our biggest areas
of acquisition for us and we were
wondering you know
every time an investor would come in and
say that we dig up the numbers we like
actually that's not true this is like
you know we have customers from Idaho
Kentucky Louisiana middle of the u.s. so
we started looking at what was really
going on and called up you know a few
customers and it turns out that we know
we rent and soil gadgets the nearest
best buy for a lot of these guys is
about 40 50 miles away they don't want
to go up there and buy something and
they have no experience they want to be
able to test it out for a few days and
the local rental stores have all shut
down and they no longer there the
brick-and-mortar stores and so they
place an order from the website to
business days it shows up with a return
label in the box they love the service
so it turns out that the middle of the
u.s. is actually a pretty big audience
for us even though on just on the first
appearance it doesn't seem like it so
always try and understand who your
target audiences it might not be the
people you think they are and if they
aren't go figure out what you can do for
us we are figuring out fulfillment from
the middle of the u.s what do we do in
that case for east coast and for west
coast we figure it out the you how do
you get to the middle of the country in
about a day's time frame the logistics
operations that side of things so figure
out who your target customer is it might
not be the people who you absolutely are
sure about and if it is in course
correct and make it happen depending on
who your customers really are so that's
really what Ohio is about and that's
basically it I would love to reach out
and talk to you if you are interested in
how we work or just want to know about
lamoid i am at RT are calm or rtl you my
comms my email address thank you